hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so let's think
about what we said just a little while
ago and let's add a few more things what
is a virtue it's a character trait right
it's something that is more than just an
action or an emotion it's not just
something that exists at one given point
in time and that never exist again if
you say that somebody is generous you're
not just saying that they're generous
right this this minute you're saying
that you can rely on them to be generous
over time right if you're saying that
somebody is loyal again if you call
somebody boil and then the next minute
they actually screw you over
you were probably wrong about them
having a character trait of loyalty I
think or something you know something
really strange
so character traits are stable and they
they last
over time what else do we need to say
about virgins well one thing is is that
they ought they do tend to be socially
approved that's an important aspect of
them the society always have the right
understanding of these these character
traits and not usually it's got some
sort of very general vague notion of
that you know what actually constitutes
generosity that that's that's a question
that you want to actually answer Society
can say yeah generosity is really good
but that's not going so far as to tell
you what actually is good about it or
what generosity yes
so they're they're a little bit more
there's more to virtue than just being
stuff that's socially approved so that's
an important part of it what else can we
say well how do you how do you get
virtues do you just sort of take a pill
and you know pill it maybe for courage
or should we make justice blue and then
how about the temperance maybe green
white for wisdom okay that's good yeah
yeah pop these pills and now suddenly
you're a good person you've got it all
squared away I mean you can't actually
take certain pills that will alter the
aspects of your personality listen not
that much and once you stop taking the
pill it goes away right somebody's got
an anger management problems and you
dope them up with something to keep them
calm all the time
that works so long as they're you know
there were systems flooded with that
take it out
dancing problems how do you acquire
virtues well it's through doing the sort
of things that are characteristic of
that virtue through behaving in a
certain way like Plato says if you want
people to be just they have to do just
actions and they're not yet just when
they first start out it takes like
habituation you have to get used to it
just like when you learn how to do
certain skills right you it felt really
weird at first
remember when you learn cursive first
you learn how to print and you probably
liked that after a while they didn't
like it at first yeah that's okay I can
print letters now all right now that
they made you do cursive and you're like
this is I don't want to do this
this is feels really awkward why can't
you just let me alone so I can just
print
I don't need cursive as a matter of fact
it looks worse than it came up with all
sorts of justifications why you didn't
want to do it
I know I was I came to that myself and
then I showed them that I'd mix purses
and printing together well what happened
after a while if you stuck with it your
crystal got better did it feel better
did it quit feeling like and in position
what about exercise when if you let
yourself get out of shape what's that
first week when you decide to get
yourself back in shape or any of you who
have been on the sport and then you were
doing conditioning for a while and then
you let it go yeah and you were still in
good shape but you weren't doing like
for that that's for it what's it like
that first week that's terrible right
what's it like the second week yeah yeah
it's still not great right but it's a
little bit better what's it like my
mom's from that really that's good it
does get easier yeah I didn't I suppose
when I was your age yeah I could I could
have that like tougher now but you get
the general idea
virtues are like that virtues become
something that becomes part of you over
time by you actually committing to them
and doing certain things and it doesn't
have to necessarily be conscious if you
want children to be virtuous you don't
you know go to them and say okay little
Johnny first we're gonna work on justice
this week now justice is this and I want
you to behave this way and this way and
here's a Plato says about it you just
make a little giant they actually behave
in just ways and you know you try to
curb some of it and at with enough
repetition and eventually it starts to
become like Aristotle says second nature
you want something to be generous model
generosity yourself right you want
somebody not to be a kid who loses their
temper immediately you got to learn how
to restrain your temper if you know if
you don't do if you have a bad because
mob so you know education practice
modeling do you have to worry about the
culture that you're in yeah don't worry
about that because they're getting
models and education through that
culture too and those may be going
against
trying to encode now these virtues so
that's a lot about virtue itself what
are the virtues that Plato talks about
he talks about three right off the bat
that connect these parts of the soul and
I think that's a word we you know we can
all wrap our hands around pretty easily
for somebody to be wise means more than
just possessing a lot of knowledge right
it means that they can actually think
out well what is good for them what is
good for other people what a given
situation requires you know here's an
example of maybe something that would
require was should you stay in your
major you know you can ask yourself am i
happy in my major and then you can ask
yourself should I stay in my major was
that going to fulfill me with the kind
of person that I want to be individually
you're thinking about that you know with
your intellect and these other parts may
be involved I mean you may be you
consult your desires you say like to
make a lot of money that's importantly
well that's one of the appetites we said
I would like to be respected that's two
most those those aren't you know to be
got rid of all together but the actual
thinking about it is done by your
intellect and when your intellect is
functioning well with that sort of thing
then you actually had wisdom how do you
think you get that way you have to do a
lot of thinking the more thinking you do
provided its thinking you know along the
rheine ways thinking about the right
things
the smarter you'll actually get here's
one you know sort of thing that Plato
doesn't talk about
probably think about you want to become
wise look for other people who are wise
and then hanging around with them a lot
and think about the things that they say
and do and eventually you'll start to
take on that pattern this part of your
personality that's a lot about wisdom
what about courage what do we think of
courage is being that's a synonym Thanks
yeah what bravery it's like doing
something in case of danger or adversity
and you like do it anyway
yeah it's a danger and adversity and how
does danger and adversity make us feel
that's interesting because because
courage at least for Plato and for years
little doesn't mean the absence of fear
altogether no you can't still be afraid
for yourself
it does involve not feeling like you
know being flooded with you know yeah
certain situation say one more time
period uncertain situation okay yeah
that would time with the danger and the
other fearful things possible harm to
you yeah okay that's now now we're
getting something that's a bit more
robust the courageous person can feel
fear they're not going to feel too much
of them in part because Plato says that
courage is actually it does involve
knowledge it's right it's like a right
assessment of how scared should I be so
if you see a spider and it's not a brown
recluse and you are like you know trying
to climb the wall there's something
wrong because that's a that's a
disproportionate amount of fear of a
little thing that's not going to do
anything to you you know brown recluse
okay maybe be afraid of that kids you
know that can actually hurt you the most
spiders are gonna leave you alone unless
you go like poke in it or something like
that alright and you're not gonna do
that but a lot of people have these kind
of phobias well what's a phobia it's an
undue disproportionate fear the
courageous person knows what they want
to be afraid of
and then when they feel they are they
actually like you said they stick to
what they're doing they they they have
that activity that's why it's part of
this part of the soul for Plato the part
of the soul that has drive energy desire
is self-respect how do you actually
what's one way to make yourself respect
abandoned people behaved courageously
stand up for yourself you know do things
that are that are kind of tough and what
happens when you actually stand up to
your fears what have you experienced
they have to go away Parker you realize
while this is real
yeah and then you start to gain a sort
of sense of confidence don't you what
about this now this is interesting to
this temperature moderation this is a
little bit different than wisdom or
courage Plato talks about this in in two
different ways he talks about her being
kind of harmonizing things he also talks
about it was sort of an obedience in a
way then he also talks about limits so
think for a moment just about where
desires all the things that you want
this goes back to that ring of conscious
thing well if you have that ring imagine
the things that you could do all the
things you could indulge yourself in
let's say we had a transportation device
to put you where you make it anytime
right
just think of the crazy things that you
might want that you might deserve what
happens to our desires if we don't have
limits on them do they limit themselves
I guess they can limit themselves in
that after they're satisfied and they're
done but if you keep indulging them
doesn't sometimes take more and more to
satisfy if you don't have limits I think
about
yeah yeah I had a cat they actually know
he was still a kid and I came back in
the store and I left like in a ground
beef in the sink he ate this was like a
five pound kid he ate close to a pound I
don't know where he stuffed it but I
knew how much there was because you know
a good portion of the package is going
and you know maybe it's sick afterwards
and all that and you know not not smart
behavior right what happens to you if
you don't restrain your food intake
within now here actually on to something
which brings us to the question of
justice justice Plato says is the virtue
that he has to do with the proper
arrangement between these parts when
they're actually in harmony with each
other you're right if you don't restrict
your desires within certain reasonable
limits if reason is not calling the
shots those desires are not going to
restrict themselves and Plato says they
look wrong and what they will do then is
then they will start telling reason hey
I want some more of this find me how to
get I don't care what you need to do
find me what I you know what other
things will get me to where I want to be
think of the attitude actually is
they're just just thinking about where
to get that next fix right they're not
thinking about is this good for me is
this a good life is this what
do for that so long as that desire is
you know charged living what can I do to
satisfy this that the more that you do
that one second more than you do that
the more on your character will come to
take take on down configuration the way
Plato thinks it ought to be some people
that's a good question some people want
to read this in terms of like super ego
ego and yet that doesn't work so well
for the top tip it works good for for
the desires the desires begin yeah it's
basically the same sort of thing the ego
is not exactly the same thing as do most
ego would also be prevalent here and
super-ego is basically internalized
commands injunctions from other people
those could be like desires you might
have your desires because you
internalize some things that yeah if you
go is disordered you wouldn't have
justice let's this is the last thing I
need stake so what's the proper order
intellect should be giving the commands
to everything else because either the
desires their appetites by themselves
can restrain order this the spirited
part of this you know that can lead us
straight to you can lead us into fights
and can lead us into trying to do
whatever it takes to you know be on top
intellect lot to tell both of these
other fronts what to do it's interesting
here this is a very important mediating
her intellect by itself in plato's
movies
strong enough to directly impose its
rule on the appetites you need the
conjunction of this middle part courage
then becomes in a way standing up to
your own desires and not fearing what's
going to happen if they're not satisfied
and if you have now you have that sort
of configuration then you have justice
and Plato says this iswell leave Plato
says that we can look at all sorts of
things that we call justice
those are external hacks like you know
not why not steel not cheating on your
spouse those sorts of things what do
they come from
they come from within the person the
just person has something within the
structure of their personality where
their soul if you like you know more
theological language that restrains them
that keeps them on the right track and
that's what justices